ja so sind bei uns aus wenn wir
moderationen drehen nebenan wird der
kicker gespielt hier steht noch ein
radioreporter in der ecke und aber das
ist super der fall
youtube ist moment nur so das thema und
hier drehen wir gleich die moderation
für krachten den neuen top ten kanal von
mir aber jetzt geht's erst mal ein fixum
und um unserem gast die comedy ihr könnt
ihr natürlich wieder fragen stellen dem
mann der mit seiner integrations umfrage
millionen views auf youtube hat und der
damit also mit der verlinkung unter
diesem video
die porsche arena in stuttgart mit 6000
leuten gefüllt hat also absoluter rekord
mandant zum fernseher gelangen wieder
auf youtube also er hat viel zu erzählen
und wenn ihr den info text unten lässt
wenn ihr dann eure fragen als kommentar
oder noch besser als video hochladen
dann kann eigentlich wie immer nichts
mehr schief gehen also ich drücke die
daumen
die auch und bis dann bleib dran